The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
IAN STEWART: So last time, we
were midway through this proof
that the equations of motion,
i.e., field redefinitions,
can be used to
simplify the theory.
And I stated last
time that really,
all we have to worry about is
the change to the Lagrangian.
But when we looked
at the path integral
to do things properly and make
a change variable in the path
integral, it wasn't just
the Lagrangian that changed.
The Lagrangian changed, and
we could set up our field
redefinition to do what we want,
but there were also changes
to the Jacobian and
the source, and that's
what we had started to
talk about last time.
So when I look at the change the
Jacobian, which is this thing,
we could write that
as a ghost Lagrangian.
And the argument for why we
don't need to worry about this
is as follows.
So the effective
field theory is going
to be valid for small momentum.
There's an expansion and
there's some scale introduced
by the higher dimensional
operators, lamda new,
and we're looking at low
momentum relative to that.
In the particular case
that we're dealing with,
this parameter eta
had dimensions,
and so lambda nu
was 1 over root eta.
And we put factors of eta in
front of our higher dimension
operators, so that's
like putting 1
over lambda nus in front
of those operators.
And the reason
that we don't have
to worry so much about
this ghost Lagrangian
is that these ghosts
are going to get mass
that's of the size lambda nu.
So what that means is that
the ghost, along with perhaps
other particles that are
up at the scale lamda new
are things that we don't
have to worry about,
and we can effectively
integrate out
the ghost from the
theory in the same way
that we would think about
removing some particles that
had masses of order lambda nu.
So I'll show you
why they get masses
of order lambda nu in a second.
So let's do that by way of
picking a particular example.
So far, we've kept things fairly
general without specifying
what this set of fields
it's in this thing
that we called T was.
We just left it as
an arbitrary thing.
Let's pick a particular T.
The argument here is actually
fairly general, but I think
it'd be easier to see it
for particular example.
So if we pick this
to be T, we have
this term which has no relation
to T. That term is important.
And then we have
the terms from this.
And so we'd have
a ghost Lagrangian
that would look like that.
So this here is going
to be the mass term,
and so far, it doesn't look like
it has the right dimensions.
And that's because we've got
our kinetic term, if you like,
with the wrong dimensions.
So if we want ghost fields
of standard dimensions,
or canonically normalized
kinetic term in this case,
we would take c and rescale
it to c over root eta.
And if we do that, then this
does become a lambda nu.
So that removes the eta in
the interaction term here.
It removes it from this kinetic
term that happened to be there,
and then the only place that
the eta's showing up now
in this case is in this term.
But now you see explicitly in
terms of these ghost fields
that they have mass lambda nu.
OK, and that's just
what I was claiming.
So the important point here
was that you did need this 1.
This 1 was playing a
very important role
in this argument.
If the 1 wasn't there,
this wouldn't work.
And that 1 was
related to something
that was part of one of
our starting assumptions,
that when we made the
field redefinition,
that the one-particle
states would stay the same.
So if you look back at what our
field redefinition was and you
trace back where
that 1 came from,
we had a field redefinition
that was of this form,
and this guy was a
function of other fields.
But we always had this
term, and that term
was related to the
presence of this 1,
and that was important
for this argument, OK.
So there has to be a term
that's linear in the new field.
You want the same
one-particle states.
So these ghosts, as
you know about ghosts,
always appear in loops.
And so if you want to
think about removing
this massive particle, it's
like a massive particle
that occurs in some loops.
It's really just like that.
So it's just like
a heavy particle
that you would remove
from the theory that
would only appear in loops.
And we're going to discuss
exactly how that works
and how to remove heavy
particles that appear in loops
in detail a little
bit later, so for now,
that's enough detail
for number two.
So are there any
questions about that?
OK, so the change
to the Jacobian
is effectively a massive ghost
that we could integrate out
of the theory.
When we integrate it
out of the theory,
it would shift the values of
the couplings in the Lagrangian,
but it doesn't have
any impact that
can't be absorbed
in other operators
in the effective theory.
So then the final thing we have
to worry about is the source.
So there is this term with j
phi dagger, and when we take--
there was an extra
term with j phi dagger
that we had last time.
I'm going to remind you
what it looked like.
So in our path integral,
we had an exponential
of a bunch of stuff,
but then there
was one final term that was
induced that involved j phi
dagger from the
field redefinition.
So when you take derivatives
with respect to j phi dagger,
there's sort of the usual
term that we want to source,
and then there's this new term.
So what about that new term?
That's the final thing
we have to worry about.
And this is where it's
important that we're actually
considering observables.
So we need to
consider observables.
So let's start by considering
some Green's functions
or time-ordered products.
So I'm just taking
a string of fields.
I could have some other
fields here as well.
I'm going to make my life a
little easier by taking the phi
to be real, and that's just
for notational simplicity.
I could write phi
dagger and phis, but.
So when we make the field
redefinition, what happens
to that time-ordered product?
So this is one way of thinking
about these extra terms
in the source.
So you take functional
derivatives with respect
to the other piece that
involves j phi, you get phi.
So if you take
[INAUDIBLE] that piece,
you get the extra eta Ts.
Or you can just think about
making the field redefinition
directly in this matrix
element, and you'd
have a matrix element
that looks like that.
So it's not at all obvious
that these extra pieces that
involve fields can't change the
value of this Green's function,
and in fact, they will change
the value of that Green's
function.
But the important
thing is that we
have to consider observables
and not just Green's functions.
So when we're going to
think about observables,
we should think about the LSZ
formula, which connects Green's
functions to S-matrix elements.
So let me remind you about that.
And I'll remind you
what it looks like.
First one is fixed
set of fields,
which are scalar fields, but
we could put fermions in it
as well.
So what this says is,
if I look at this--
so it's an integral
over the spacetime.
I'm sticking in
particular momentum
for the particular fields.
And if I look at it, if I
look at the leading term,
the leading pole term as the
particles are taken on shell,
then that's an observable
known as the S-matrix.
So some number of these
particles are incoming.
Some number of
them are outgoing.
That affects the sign that
I put in this plus minus.
I'm not trying to be too
detailed about which ones are
outgoing, which ones are
incoming, but some of them
are incoming, some
of them are outgoing.
And for each one, I want to
strip off the leading pole.
I want to look at
the coefficient,
and it has to have
a pole, so this is
a product over all particles.
We really need to pull in all
the different cases and all
for all the external
particles, OK.
So if I wanted to
make this an equality,
I'd say plus dot dot dot.
There's other terms, and
the thing that's observable
is the coefficient
of these poles, not
the Z but this thing.
So if I make changes to my
theory and they effect this
thing but get cancelled
by this thing,
as long as they don't
affect this thing, we're OK.
And the claim is that we make
this change to the source
and it won't affect the
matrix on the S, the S-matrix.
So again, we can
do some examples,
and I think the examples are
fairly quickly convincing
that this is the case.
So we'll do three
different examples,
first a rather trivial one.
What if T was just by itself?
So T is just phi, so this
is just 1 plus eta phi.
So if you think
back, when we have T,
this was the form of
the terminal Lagrangian,
so this is just eta
phi del squared phi,
so it's just changing
the kinetic term for phi.
If we look at our
matrix on it, we're
just getting a factor of 1 plus
eta for each of the fields.
So let's say we had 4 of them
just so we don't have to--
so say I had 4 of them.
If I had n of them, it would
just be to the nth power,
but if I have power of them,
they'd be to the fourth power,
and I'd just get
this extra prefactor.
And it looks like
it's changed G.
And indeed, it has changed
the left-hand side of this
equation, but when we calculate
the z factor and we canonically
normalize--
if you want to think
about it that way--
then we would exactly cancel
off these 1 plus etas.
So the root Z here is going
to be 1 plus eta as well.
So when we look at the--
this is just the residue
of the free propagator.
The residue gets changed when
you change the kinetic term,
so that doesn't do
anything to the S-matrix.
So that's one way
we can be protected.
We change the left-hand side.
It's compensated by a change to
the Z and leaves S invariant.
Let's do another example,
a little more non-trivial.
So let's just take some cubic
term in our field redefinition.
So this is like having a 5
cubed del squared phi term.
So this extra term
will give rise
to extra terms in
the primary product.
And let me just
write one of them,
again thinking of it
as a 4-point function.
So let's just imagine I look
at the change that comes
from changing the 4th guy.
So there's other terms from
changing 5x1, 5x2 and 5x3,
but if I work to order eta,
then I'd change one of them
at a time, and we're only
working to order eta here.
So the claim is actually
that this matrix element has
no effect on this structure.
It can affect the
dots, but it's not
going to affect
the leading term,
and that's because
having a 5 cubed
means that you're not
having a one-particle state.
So if you try to draw it
as a [INAUDIBLE] diagram,
in the position space, you'd
label these external points
and you inject momenta there.
And then we label point 4, but
there's three fields there,
so maybe we have to tie it
up like this or something.
And when you look at
asymptotically what's
going to happen from
[INAUDIBLE] a 5 cubed,
you do not get a single-particle
pole from a 5 cubed.
So this guy is less singular.
There's no single-particle
pole, and hence,
gives no contribution
to scatter.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: As far as
the theorem goes,
this step that you're showing,
it proves my hypothesis, right?
IAN STEWART: In what sense?
AUDIENCE: The hypothesis
of the theorem
is that [INAUDIBLE] does not
change a one-particle state.
IAN STEWART: That's right.
That was an assumption.
AUDIENCE: I mean, is that
the same as what you're--
IAN STEWART: It's
the same, yeah.
It's effectively the
same, though it's
being more careful about what
the statement of that means,
right, because I mean,
you're changing the residue
but you're not
changing the S-matrix.
AUDIENCE: Right.
This is what I was thinking
when you said that.
IAN STEWART: Yeah, all right.
So really, this statement of--
yeah, I could have been
a little more careful.
So instead of saying that
the hypothesis of the theorem
is that it wouldn't change
one-particle states, what
I should have really said is
that there's a linear term
in the field redefinition.
Yeah, which now I'm showing you
is equivalent to not changing
the one-particle states.
And let's do one
final example just
to rule out all
possible things we could
think of that are different.
So what if we had a derivative
[INAUDIBLE] squared phi prime?
So then we would
do the following.
We could add and
subtract a mass term.
The reason we would want to do
that is, if we looked at a term
like this, it's, again, less
singular than this term.
If this term is giving
the one particle state,
this term has got a factor
of the propagator upstairs.
So if you look for a pole that
would come from that term,
it's canceling out.
You get p squared
minus m squared
over p squared minus m squared.
So there's no pole
from this term.
And this term is,
again, just of the type
from our first example.
It's just shifting
5 by some constant.
So probably to get
dimensions right,
I should put some
factors of eta in here.
So again, something like
that doesn't change anything,
because it can be
decomposed into something
that has no pole
and then something
that's just a shift, OK?
So as long as you have this
linear term in your field
redefinition, and it doesn't
have to even have a trivial--
it doesn't have to even
have a trivial prefactor.
You could have 2 times
phi or whatever you like,
because that'll cancel out when
you normalize things correctly.
As long as you have that
linear term, you're fine.
And you don't have to worry
about changes to the Jacobian
or changes from the source term.
So you just have the changes to
the Lagrangian to worry about.
You don't have to think
about the path integral.
Just make field redefinitions
on the Lagrangian.
And that's what you'll
get some practice
with on the problem set.
So as I said at the beginning
before everybody was here,
there's a problem set
number 1 that's posted.
Everyone should make sure that
they can actually access it.
And if they can't access it,
they should let me know--
if you can't get
access to the web page.
Any final questions about
this before we move on?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I get
nervous about trying
to cancel a pole by adding an
m squared term, because then, I
guess, at some point,
you start to worry
that masses get shifted when you
start [? normalizing these. ?]
IAN STEWART: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, you should be
careful about that, too.
But you don't have
to worry about it.
Yeah.
You could think of it as doing
the mass renormalization first
and then worry about this, or--
so that you're using a
renormalized mass here.
All right.
So we'll start a new section.
And the goal of this
section is basically
to be more careful
about loop diagrams
and, in particular,
to show you what
matching is between two
effective field theories.
We'll still be thinking in the
context of mass of particles.
That's the simplest
place to describe this
that we'll probably do an
example later on of a case that
doesn't just involve
mass of particles.
So let's start out with a
very trivial example just
to see what we're talking about.
So we'll take two particles.
One of them is a heavy scalar.
It has mass capital
M. Actually, I
put a little
underline so you can
tell my capitals
from my lowercase,
because the light
fermion that we're also
going to have has a
lowercase mass, little m.
OK.
So heavy scalar, light fermion.
And so what we want
to talk about here
is really this picture that
we described to you earlier
where we've got two
theories, 1 and 2,
and we want to pass
from theory 1 to 2
by removing something
from theory 1.
So theory 1 here will be just
the theory of these things.
And we'll make it a
renormalizable theory,
in the traditional sense,
just so we know where to stop.
And this guy should be capital.
And then there's some
[INAUDIBLE] interaction
between them.
So we'll think of this
as being the theory 1,
where we're in a situation
where capital M is
much bigger than little m.
So then we want to think about
describing psi at low energies.
And that means we can
get rid of the scalar
as an explicit
degree of freedom.
So low energy is relative
to this mass scale,
which is heavy--
M, capital M. We're
going to remove
the scalar from the theory.
So you could just
say remove it, or you
could say integrate it out.
When you say integrate
out, the words you're using
have a path-integral
connotation,
where you had this [INAUDIBLE]
in the path integral,
and you think about
just doing the path
integral over that
field and removing it.
But the words of "removing
it" or "integrating it out"
are synonymous.
So what is theory 2
going to look like?
Well, we'll still have the
kinetic term for our fermion.
And then removing
the scalar will
generate some new operators.
In particular, there'll be
a dimension-six operator
like this.
And then there could
well be other terms.
And so if we wanted
to figure out
what this dimension-six
operator is at tree level,
that's a pretty
straightforward exercise.
We would simply think about the
Feynman diagram in theory 1.
So here's a Feynman diagram
in theory 1 with [INAUDIBLE]
couplings here.
We would calculate
this Feynman diagram.
And we would assume
that all the momentum
of the external
particles are small.
And that means
that this is small.
And we would just expand.
And then we would just ask
that, when I take the Feynman
rule from this--
whoops, should have
been a square there--
when I take the
Feynman rule from that,
then I should get the same thing
as the Feynman rule from that.
And that would fix
this coefficient a,
which is, so far, arbitrary.
But we can determine
it by using theory 1.
And that's the idea of doing a
matching calculation that you
have introduced the theory 2.
It has some parameters
in front of operators.
In this case, I called it a.
And we want to determine
those parameters by doing
calculations in theory 1.
And in particular,
what you do is
you make sure that S-matrix
elements in the two theories
agree.
But at tree level, that's
just matching up diagrams.
So a is simply g squared.
So we just have to match
up this guy with that guy.
And so taking the leading-order
term, a is just g squared.
Very simple.
So the place where this gets
more involved and more--
where you have to think
a little bit more-- this
seems almost automatic,
that you just do
calculations in here and
here, and just match them up.
And that's the basic idea.
It's only a little
more complicated
when you have to take
into account loops.
So that's what we'll spend most
of this section discussing,
since this part is easier.
So what about loops?
What are some of the
issues that come up there?
Well, the first one is that
the Feynman diagrams diverge,
so you have to regulate them.
And the thing that can be
confusing about thinking
about effective field theories
and thinking about divergence
diagrams is separating the
ideas of regularization
and the mass scale lambda nu
that we've been talking about.
So that's something
I want to talk
about in some detail, because
they're not the same thing.
So we would need to cut
off ultraviolet divergences
to obtain finite results.
And that means we
introduce cutoff parameters
into our results.
So examples would be taking
the Minkowski momentum,
continuing it to be Euclidean,
and then just putting
a hard cutoff on it--
that's one example.
Or you could use dim reg.
That's another example.
Or you could use
a lattice spacing.
That's another example.
So these are all
examples of how you
might cut off the theory to
remove ultraviolet divergences.
And then there's a second
step, renormalization,
distinct from regularization.
So some of the things
I'm teaching you here
should be familiar.
And the only real generalization
that we're going to do
is we're going to be able
to apply some of the things
that you learned
about renormalization
and regularization
to any operators
that you might
have in the theory,
whether they're renormalizable
in the dimension-four
traditional sense or in a
higher-dimensional sense.
So here, what we're doing when
we talk about renormalization
is we're picking a
scheme that gives
precise or definite
meaning to the parameters
in the effective theory.
Or, even more explicitly, each
coefficient in the Lagrangian,
as well as the operators
in the Lagrangian,
are given a meaning
by this procedure.
If we didn't have a
renormalization procedure,
then, because of the
ultraviolet divergences,
there'd be ambiguities in how
we define the coefficients
and the operators.
Or, even if you don't have
ultraviolet divergences,
you still have freedom
to pick different schemes
for the definitions
of the coefficients.
And when you do this, you
also can introduce parameters.
So you can get parameters
from regularization.
You can also get
parameters from this.
So some examples
that are familiar--
there's this scale mu that
shows up when you do MS bar.
If you do something
that's a little bit
different, if you take
Green's functions,
and you go to some
offshell point,
that's another renormalization
scheme called offshell momentum
subtraction.
And that scheme also has
a parameter that shows up.
And if you did a
Wilsonian renormalization,
there would also be a
cutoff associated to that.
And this Wilsonian
cutoff here doesn't
have to be the same as
this lambda uv cutoff.
OK.
So every coefficient,
every operator,
no matter the
dimension, no matter
where it turns up
in the series, we're
going to have to think
about whether there's
diagrams that generate
ultraviolet divergences.
And if those diagrams
look like these operators,
then you're going to
get renormalization
of those operators.
And you're going to have to
be careful about taking care
of those divergences
and also the scheme
that you define
the operators in.
So you can think about
this, just as far
as the coefficients
are concerned,
as starting out with some
bare coefficients that
depend on your
ultraviolet regulator,
and switching to some
renormalized coefficients which
don't depend on the
ultraviolet regulator
but do depend on the scheme.
And then, also, you
have some counterterms
that depend on both things.
So that's how it
would look if you
wrote that down for a
cutoff, in a Wilsonian sense.
If you wrote it down in
dimensional regularization,
it would look like this.
Same idea, different
names for the parameters.
OK.
So in dimensional
regularization,
epsilon is the
ultraviolet regulator.
It shows up in the
bare coefficients.
The renormalized ones don't
depend on epsilon anymore.
And these are your
1-over-epsilon poles.
All right.
So one of the things
that makes this tricky
is when you start thinking
about your power counting.
And so I want to spend a few
minutes talking about that.
So let's consider this
example that I wrote down
with the four-fermion operator.
And if we just loop up
the four-fermion operator,
then we can get mass
renormalization.
So this is psi
dagger psi squared.
And I'm sticking it
in and looping it up.
So we start out with a
tree-level mass, little m.
But there's a
one-loop correction
that involves one of our
higher-dimension operators.
And there's some
connection to the mass,
which I'll call delta m.
I'm not going to worry too much
about the overall prefactor.
This operator came with
an a over M squared.
And then there's
a loop integral.
There's a fermionic propagator,
so that's a k slash plus m
over k squared minus m squared.
This guy here drops away.
And really, we just have a
correction that's a scalar.
And that's a correction to the
mass scalar in the spin space.
So it's a, little m,
over capital M, and then
just this integral.
And if we continue
it to be Euclidean,
then it looks like that if
I continue from Minkowski
to Euclidean.
That's why I put the i there.
So if we just assume
that this integral that's
sitting there-- there's only
one mass scale that seems
explicit there-- the little m.
So if we just assume
that that integral is
dominated by the scale m--
little m-- then you
could do a power counting
for this loop integral.
You just assume that
all the factors of k
are of order little m.
You've got an explicit little
m, four powers in the numerator,
and two powers downstairs.
So you would say that this
integral scales like m squared.
And then you would put that
together with your delta m
and say that delta m scales like
a, little m cubed, capital M
squared.
And so this is something that
would then be suppressed.
Relative to the original
tree-level contribution,
it would be suppressed
by, perhaps,
some [? 4 pi ?]
[? is in ?] the loop,
but also little m squared
over big M squared.
So it would be a small
correction, which is really
what we would like to be
the case when we're talking
about some higher-dimension
operator that
was supposed to be suppressed.
We'd like it to be
a small correction.
All right.
So does anyone have any
idea what can go wrong
with this argument?
I've been glib about it.
I just said, if the integral
is dominated by that.
So the thing is that
we have to be careful
about our choice of regulator,
because regulators also
can introduce scales.
So let's do this more carefully.
Well, let's consider
two different choices
for the regulator.
So we'll start out with
just a cutoff, which
seems very natural, from
an effective field theory
point of view-- that your theory
is supposed to be only valid up
to some scale.
So why not just take and cut
off the momentum explicitly
above some scale?
And you can think of that
scale as being of order big M.
So we just don't
include any momentum
that are higher than that
scale in our loop integrals.
So we're only integrating over
the region in momentum space
where the theory is
supposed to be valid.
It seems like a perfectly
reasonable thing to do.
So in this case, we can
take this integral that
has some angular parts to
it as well as a radial part,
decompose it into the radial
piece and the angular piece.
I'll give you a handout, or I'll
post a page of lecture notes
that have all those fun formulas
that are useful to remember
but not fun to talk about
for decomposing integrals
in arbitrary dimensions into
radial and angular pieces.
So if we do that, in this
case, then the radial
integral-- we can cut
off the radial integral
with a hard cutoff lambda uv.
And just by dimensions, the d
4 k becomes kE times kE cubed.
So this is a radial k now.
And this integral,
we can do exactly.
There's a loop
factor, 4 pi squared.
There's a lambda uv squared.
And then there's a logarithm.
It goes like, lambda uv
squared over little m squared.
There's two scales
that are showing up--
lambda uv and little m.
The answer depends
on both of them.
And then we can start
expanding, because little m
is supposed to be much
smaller than lambda uv.
Let me pull out an a
m over 4 pi squared.
So there would be
a logarithmic term.
There's this lambda uv
squared over capital
M squared if I put
that factor in.
And then there's some--
so everything I'm writing
in the square brackets
here is dimensionless.
This has the right
dimensions of a mass.
OK.
So you can see
that, if I do this,
it's not satisfying
what I said over here.
I'd like the correction to
be m cubed over M squared.
There are corrections that go
like m cubed over M squared,
like this one.
These ones are even higher.
But there's this term.
And that's not a
small correction.
So for that particular
piece, what you're finding
is that your power
counting-- your naive power
counting-- of the
loop was wrong,
because there's a
piece from k of order--
the cutoff that's contributing
for that part of it.
And that's why your naive
scaling argument didn't work.
Now, this is the
bare result. And we
have to go through the
renormalization procedure.
And so if we go through the
renormalization procedure,
you can think of that as taking
a piece of the integral--
so in a Wilsonian
sense, you would
take a piece of the integral and
absorb it into the counterterm.
So as promised, the
counterterm depends
on both lambda uv and lambda.
And those are just explicitly--
I'm cutting off the
radial integral here.
And that does improve things,
because then, I can lower
this cutoff, make it smaller.
And what is left would just be
lambda squared over capital M
squared and log of m squared
over capital lambda squared.
So I change the lambda
uv's up here into lambdas
by that procedure.
So when I renormalize,
the psi bar psi
squared matrix element--
there's a correction from that
to the mass.
And the renormalized thing would
depend on this Wilsonian cutoff
lambda, OK?
But I'm not fully
getting around the issue
that I'm generating
this type of term.
So let's do it with a
different regulator, which
is dimensional regularization.
Let's see what happens
using the MS-bar scheme.
Same calculation.
So again, split it into
radial and angular parts.
And again, I'll
give you formulas
for doing something like that.
But I won't write
them down in lecture.
Actually, I think I will
write one down a little later.
But I'll give you a more
complete set as a handout.
So leaving over
the radial integral
but regulating it
dimensionally just
means that, instead of having
this guy to the cubed power,
it's to the d minus 1.
And there's some pieces
here that depend on epsilon.
And my convention
for the entire course
is that d is 4 minus 2
epsilon, not d minus epsilon.
So again, this is an
integral we can do exactly.
We get something like that.
And then we can expand.
We get a 1-over-epsilon pole.
We get a logarithm.
There is some constant as well.
And then there's
order-epsilon pieces.
So you should contrast
this result here
with the result
we had over here.
The order-epsilon pieces
are like these terms.
They're the terms that would go
away if I took the cutoff here
to infinity-- lambda uv to
infinity or epsilon to 0.
There's terms here that go
like m cubed over M squared.
That's like this term.
And this term is not there.
This 1 over epsilon is
related to the log divergence.
And this thing here
is a power divergence.
So the 1 over epsilon is related
to this log of lambda uv.
You should think
of log of lambda uv
as going to 1 over epsilon
plus log of mu squared.
But we don't see
the power divergence
in dimensional
regularization in MS bar.
OK.
So what's happening
is, from this result,
we are getting something that's
the size that we expected
by our power-counting argument.
The regularized result is the
right size by power counting.
The logarithm here is the same
log as in a with, if you like,
a correspondence
between mu and lambda.
So we're seeing that
logarithm there.
We're just not seeing this term.
And if we wanted to write
down the MS-bar counterterm.
Some correction to the mass,
it would go like, a, m squared.
The diagram would look like
just the 1-over-epsilon pole
in MS bar.
OK.
So the two regulators seem to
give us similar results but not
exactly-identical results.
And the question is, how
should I think about this?
What's the right way of
thinking about this extra term?
So there's a
language that people
use in effective field
theory and dimensional
counting for the
difference between thinking
about doing a regularization
of type A and type B.
And what you say
is that, in type B,
your regularization
of the problem
does not break the
power counting, which
means that you can do power
counting for regulated graphs
prior to renormalization them.
But you can see that, in case
A, that would be problematic,
because our naive power
counting wouldn't have given us
the right result.
So what do we say about case A?
Well, if case B didn't
break the power counting,
then case A does.
But you can say something
a little bit more positive
about case A. And that is that,
when you think about case A,
you can set up the theory with
renormalization conditions
such that you can
restore power counting
in the renormalized graphs
and renormalized couplings
and renormalized operators.
But you don't have power
counting-- explicit power
counting-- in just the
regularized results.
So you can think
that I just take
the Wilsonian cutoff
small enough that I
make that annoying term small.
And order by order,
I can do that--
order by order in
my loop expansion,
my calculations.
OK.
So in some sense,
there's nothing wrong
with doing A. It's
just that you have
to work a little harder
to think about it.
And when you think about
the power counting,
you have to do that for the
renormalized quantities,
not for the bare quantities.
So if you like, what
you're doing here
is you're adding counterterms.
Another way you can say this is
that you're adding counterterms
to restore the power
counting that you want.
And that's not too
different than--
you could always
do that, actually.
I made this analogy
that you should
think about power counting
as being like gauge symmetry.
So let's say you had a theory,
and it had nice gauge symmetry,
but you picked some
crazy regulator
that broke gauge symmetry.
Well, you could always
put counterterms
in that would break
gauge symmetry
and restore it in the
renormalized quantity.
That would be OK.
It would be more work.
We don't like to do that.
We avoid it at all costs.
But if we had to,
we could do it.
If you do
supersymmetry, you might
try to use dimensional
regularization
and supersymmetry, standard
dimensional regularization
and supersymmetry,
break supersymmetry.
If you do that, you have
to introduce counterterms
that restore supersymmetry.
So the same language of
symmetry is being applied here,
except now to power
counting, where
we say that if your regulator
messes up your power counting,
you can restore it in the
renormalized couplings.
But you may be smart enough
to think up a regulator--
in this case, dimensional
regularization--
where you don't have to
deal with that complication.
OK.
So let me write that.
So in an effective
theory, you should
think about regulating
to preserve symmetries
as well as to preserve
power counting, if you can.
And one way, in a
more formal language,
that you could say what
happens with the generation
of that term that we talked
about with the cutoff
is that you'd mix up different
orders in the expansion,
and it looks like your
naively higher-order term
is mixing back to a
term of lower dimension.
And so if you can get away with
taking a regulator that doesn't
have that mixing back to
more relevant operators,
then you could preserve
your power counting,
make it simpler.
This is true irrespective of
what the power counting is in.
This is a general statement.
In the context of what
we've been talking about,
which is dimensional
power counting,
there's a particular phrase
that goes along with this.
And that is that we talk
about using a mass independent
regulator, like dim reg.
If you like, it has
a mass scale, mu,
but it's put in
softly in a way that
doesn't mess up power counting.
We call that using a mass
independent regulator.
So we want to avoid
having different orders
in the expansion mix
up with each other.
In general, I should
comment, then,
that terms that
are the same order
will definitely typically
mix up with each other
under renormalization.
So even if you thought
you were smart,
and you enumerated all the
operators, but you missed one,
and then you
started calculating,
that operator might
just pop out at you,
because you could
have some calculation
with another operator
mix into that operator.
Or you could have an operator
that you did a matching at tree
level, and you didn't
generate, but then you
start renormalizing that
tree-level operator,
and another operator
pops out at you.
So it's important that you
include all the operators that
have the same dimension and
the same quantum numbers,
because if you
don't include them,
you're bound to get
them from loops anyway.
And you want to be complete.
So if you like, in a matrix
[INAUDIBLE] notation,
you could say that the bare
operators mix up with the set
of possible
renormalized operators,
and there's some matrix of
counterterms that would correct
them--
connect them.
OK.
So any questions so far?
So sometimes, in the literature,
you'll see that these kinds
of things-- regulator
discussions in effective field
theory--
generate all sorts of papers.
Keep this in mind if
you ever run into that.
You should be able to
think about the physics
that you're after with
different regulators
and come to the same conclusion.
And it just may be easier with
one regulator versus another.
So we've said, in
these kind of theories
where we have dimensional
power counting,
that dimensional
regularization is special.
So I want to talk
a bit more about
dimensional regularization.
So sometimes you'll hear people
say that you should always
use dimensional regularization
for doing the power counting.
But that's not quite true in
the way that I've told you.
It's not that you
have to, it's just
that it makes things simpler.
But given that we want to make
things as simple as possible,
let's take dimensional
regularization seriously.
So you can actually derive
dimensional regularization
by just imposing axioms.
If you say that you want a loop
integration that's linear--
I should have said this earlier.
So my notation with
dimensional regularization
is, I put a little
cross on the d.
And that means
dividing by the 2 pi.
So that means d d p
over 2 pi to the d.
So linearity means that if I'm
integrating some function that
can be decomposed into
a sum of two pieces, a
and b being constants,
f and g being functions,
then I can write that
out as an integral over f
plus an integral over g,
which really is something
that almost every reasonable
definition of the integration
will satisfy.
The second one is translations,
which is more restricting.
So that says, if you have
some integral over f,
but it's a function of p
plus q-- q is some external--
I can always shift away the q.
It just goes-- p
goes to p minus q.
And then I just have
an integral over p.
And along with
translations, you can
think about having rotations.
My whole notation is covariance,
so we won't worry so much
about rotations.
and Lorentz group.
And then the final
one that's obviously
a little bit special to
dim reg is a scaling.
So let's say we have a scalar
s multiplying our momentum p.
Then we can rescale the
momentum p and get rid of--
pull the s outside by just
taking p goes to p over s.
So that changes this to a p.
We get an s to the minus d.
It pulls out front.
And if we demand
that, then that's
special to dimensional
regularization,
because you can see
that this depends on d.
Even if I call this measure
some abstract thing,
now there's a d showing up.
It's outside the measure.
And these three
together actually give
a unique definition
to the integration up
to the overall normalization.
And that unique
thing is dim reg.
So I'm going to
refer you to reading,
I have posted a chapter
from Collins' book
on regularization.
And around page 65, he talks
about how you prove that.
It's not too hard.
The standard definition
of the normalization,
which is something
you have to specify,
is that you let,
say, this Gaussian
integral be pi to the d over 2.
So then, from that, you have
some measure in some space
that you can then just use.
So one formula that
I used earlier on
was the ability to
split that into pieces
which were a radial piece
and then an angular piece.
And in general,
this is a property
that this integration
[? measure obeys, ?]
that you could split it, and
you could split it further.
You could pull out another
angle, for example,
and get one less dimension
in the angular parts.
And the uv divergences, if we're
talking about us divergences--
they're occurring in
this radial part--
Euclidean radial part.
So by thinking about this
kind of decomposition,
you're moving the
uv divergences to
a one-dimensional integration,
at least at one loop.
And you can always do that.
So in general, in
dimensional regularization,
there's many ways you could
evaluate the integral.
You're not used
to using this one.
You're used to keeping
things covariant,
using some Feynman parameters,
combining propagators together,
and then doing the integral.
But you could also
do it this way,
and you get the same answer.
So it's really a well-defined
measure in the sense
that you can manipulate
it in different ways.
And they should all lead to
the same answer for your loop
integrals.
And that's part
of what I'm trying
to emphasize by saying
that you could derive it
by considering axioms.
So d was equal to
4 minus 2 epsilon.
Epsilon greater
than 0 is what you
need to lower the powers of
p, and therefore tame the uv.
Epsilon less than 0
can be used to regulate
infrared singularities.
There's some
counterintuitive facts
about dimensional
regularization,
and I want to mention a
couple of them to you.
One of them is that, if I
have p to an arbitrary power--
think of it as Euclidean--
that's 0.
So Collins constructs
a proof of this
on page 71, which is actually
a little more involved,
in general.
I'll just give you an idea
of how you can see that,
from using our axioms,
that something like this
better be true.
So let's consider
a special example
that won't be enough to
prove it for arbitrary alpha.
This is any alpha.
Let's consider a
special example that
at least will be enough
to prove it for integers.
So we'll consider k's
that are integers.
And we'll think of k's
that are greater than 0.
So if I just expand out
this p plus q squared,
then the first term
is p to the 2k.
Then I get some coefficient,
p to the 2k minus 2,
q squared, some coefficient,
p to the 2k minus 4,
q to the fourth, et cetera.
In general, there's p
dot q terms as well.
But then I could do integral--
angular average and
combine those together
with these terms.
And that's why I'm not being
very explicit about what
the coefficients are.
But they're some
positive numbers.
Now, I could also take this
integral, and I could shift.
That was one of our axioms.
And that is p to the 2k.
So that means that all these
terms here better be 0.
And they have to be 0 for
arbitrary q and arbitrary k,
or any k under the
assumptions that we used,
which are that it's an
integer and it's positive.
So I could expand
it in this way.
And so therefore, we have
all these integrals over p
to the powers.
And they better be 0.
And that's enough to prove
this for integer alphas--
positive integer alphas.
OK.
And so if you want to fill
in between the integers
and you want to do
the negative cases,
then you have to
look at Collins.
But you could do that, too.
Then it requires a little
more heavy lifting.
There's one fact about this--
fact number one--
which is a little bit
subtle, and you
have to be careful.
And it's worth noting.
So let me do another
example, which
is by way of warning you
that this can sometimes
be dangerous.
So let's think of a
scalar-field theory
and a simple loop
diagram like this.
But let's take 0
momentum and 0 mass.
So if you do that, you'll
encounter an integral
that looks like this.
There's two propagators,
so I get a p
to the fourth downstairs,
and I get d d p.
And that integral is 0, but
it's 0 in a special way.
It's 0 due to a cancellation
between ultraviolet and
infrared physics.
I said that epsilon
could be regulating
both infrared
divergences as well
as ultraviolet divergences.
If I only used
epsilon to regulate
ultraviolet divergences,
I'd get a 1-over-epsilon uv.
But in this integral, I'm
actually using it to do both.
It's regulating an infrared
divergence as well.
And it just comes in
with the opposite sign.
And since epsilon uv is
equal to epsilon IR--
they're just notation to
signify what region of physics
is giving the divergence--
you get 0.
But even though
that's true, that
doesn't mean you don't
have to add a counterterm
for this diagram, because
counterterms are supposed
to cancel ultraviolet
divergences, not infrared ones,
OK?
So even though it's 0, you
still need to add a counterterm,
because the 0 is
actually a cancellation
between ultraviolet
and infrared physics.
So there's some counterterm.
And it would be
exactly of this sort,
because this is the epsilon uv.
And then if you add the bare
diagram plus the counterterm,
the answer is non-zero.
You've canceled, if
you like, the uv pole,
and you've left
over the IR pole.
OK.
So you have to be a
bit careful about using
dimensional regularization,
because if you encounter
scaleless integrals, it
could be that they actually
are affecting counterterm.
And if you want to do
some renormalization-group
improvement of the theory
or something like that,
you have to be aware of this.
If you know that all the
infrared poles are going
to cancel because you're looking
at some infrared safe quantity,
then you can be a little
bit glib about this,
because if they're going
to cancel in the end,
that means that any of
these corresponding uv poles
will also cancel.
But it's not always the case
that you're renormalizing
operators that have no
1-over-epsilon IR's [INAUDIBLE]
have to be careful about this.
So this is a subtlety that
sometimes people get wrong
when they write papers.
So dim reg is beautiful, but
there are some things about it
that are a little bit tricky.
Another thing that can be
confusing about dim reg
is that it does this, that it
regulates both uv and IR poles.
And even though it's doing
that, and even though you
need different
values of epsilon,
if you want to do
that, it's actually
still a well-defined
procedure, even
in the presence of
uv and IR poles,
even if they're both
in the same integral.
And basically, you're using
analytic continuation here.
So let me give you a
little example which
is not exactly related to this
but will allow me to show you
both how you use
analytic continuation
and how you could think about
separating uv and IR poles.
So we'll start out
just by thinking
about analytic continuation.
So suppose I had some integral.
So what does analytic
continuation mean?
Or, how should I construct it?
So let me, again, write it
in a way where I've separated
out the radial integral.
And let's suppose that
this integral here
is perfectly well-defined
for d in some range.
So this is well-defined for
some range of positive d.
And then let's say that
we wanted to continue
that integral to negative d.
Now, the problem
with negative d may
be that, when you
get to negative d,
you're getting some
infrared divergences,
and you have to figure
out how to deal with them.
And you can do this, if
you'd like, step by step.
So if we wanted to extend the
lower limit down to minus 2
from 0, then we would
do the following.
We take our integral,
write it out
in this angular/radial
separation,
split up, in the radial
variable, the piece that's
ultraviolet, which is
the high-momentum piece,
from the piece that's infrared.
And in the piece
that's infrared,
we could also just do some
addition and some subtraction
to make it more
convergent as p goes to 0.
So for example, we
could subtract f at 0.
This thing would fall off
faster and hence, give
more powers of p.
And we could make it
more convergent at 0.
And then we just integrate the
subtraction up to the cutoff c.
And the idea of
introducing this cutoff c
is that we split the uv piece
and the ultraviolet piece.
And so we can do one
kind of continuation
for d up here, making
epsilon positive,
one kind of
continuation down here.
And the result, when we
put these back together,
is independent of c, OK?
So that's the sense, actually,
in which what I said up here
is--
that you can use it for
both uv and IR divergences,
because you could always
introduce some parameter
c to split--
they're occurring in different
regions of space base,
so you could always split
them up, regulate each one
with different values of d, and
then put them back together.
And the answer, when you
put them back together,
is independent of c.
OK.
Now, if you wanted to define--
that was one of our goals.
The other one was
just to show you
what we mean by
analytic continuation.
So since it's independent
of c, then you
could do the following.
So for minus 2 less
than d less than 0,
let's take c goes to infinity.
And so for that
particular range, what you
find, then, if you
take that limit--
Well, because of the
c to the minus d,
the c is downstairs
if d is negative.
So that term goes
away, and you're just
left with this term.
This term here goes
away, too, because c
approaches the upper limit,
and everything is regulated.
And so I just would
be left with that.
OK.
Making d negative is--
So that would be the definition.
So you can see some
of the kind of tricks
that you could use with
dimensional regularization
or adding and subtracting terms.
And these are the things
that are valid things to do.
Any questions about that?
OK.
So when we do dimensional
regularization in MS bar,
you're used to doing
that for a gauge theory.
That's what you've
learned about.
But you can also do it for
any effective field theory.
And the logic is the same.
So let me remind you of
the gauge-theory logic
and then just tell you how you
would define MS bar precisely
for the fermionic effective
theory with the "psi bar psi
squared" operator that we had.
So we talked about
dimensional regularization.
Let's talk about the MS scheme.
So if we've set up our
effective theory in a way
where we've made the
mass scale explicit,
which is often a
nice thing to do--
and we did that when we
set up the effective theory
where you have the capital
M showing up explicitly.
If you do that,
then the couplings
start out dimensionless.
And that's a nice thing, to
have dimensionless coupling.
And the MS scheme
is simply the scheme
where you want to
introduce a scale
to keep the renormalized
couplings dimensionless.
So the example
you're familiar with
is just having a gauge coupling.
And if you go through the
dimensions of the fields
here, which I do in
my notes, but I'm
going to assume that you've
got some familiarity with this,
you find that the bare
coupling has dimension epsilon.
And so you define a renormalized
coupling as dimensionless.
And you introduce a factor
of mu to the epsilon.
So you say g bare,
which has dimensions,
some dimensionless z factor,
some mu to the epsilon
to make up those dimensions.
And then left over is the
renormalized coupling.
And the idea and the strategy
for any other coupling
in the effective
theory is the same,
so let's do one other example.
So take our [? dimension-six ?]
a bare over capital M squared,
psi bar psi squared.
Do dimension counting
on this guy, which
I do, again, in the notes.
But if you go through
that dimension
counting, and you remember that
the dimensions for the fermions
are assigned by
the kinetic term--
so we have a dimension
counting for the fermions.
We know that this is
dimension minus 2.
The whole thing
has to add up to d.
So that tells us
what the a bare is.
And we get 4 minus
d, in this case.
And so then we can write down
a formula analogous to that one
but for the a coefficient.
And it's mu to the 2 epsilon.
OK.
So it's as simple as that.
So in looking at
the action where
this is a term in
the Lagrangian,
we want to ensure that,
when we go to the--
that we figure out the
dimensions of this guy
in dimensional regularization.
That's 4 minus d, which
we determine from knowing
the other pieces here.
And then we just
make a redefinition
to give a
dimensionless coupling.
So that's how MS bar will work.
Well, this is MS, but this
is how minimal subtraction
works for defining all the
operators that you may have.
And then minimal subtraction
is simply a rescaling.
And that's the same as it is in
gauge theory, where we get rid
of some annoying factors,
and [? g is ?] a slightly
different definition.
So this was MS,
and this is MS bar.
OK.
So it really works in a very
similar way to gauge theory.
And you figure out
the factors of mu
to the epsilon to include in
your calculation this way.
Sometimes you see
books do it by saying
the loop measure is continued
within mu to the epsilon.
That's not right.
This is right.
If you do that, you'll
get into trouble--
not always.
That's why the books
can get away with it.
But in general, you'll
get into trouble.
All right.
So we should stop there.